hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called waplala
spoilers ahead watch out and stay safe
the movie opens in an alternate World
there waplala a tiny man with magical
powers is running through a forest as he
makes his way to a small tunnel he turns
animals into statues to protect himself
from being eaten the tunnel opens into
the real world inside the kitchen
cabinet of a young boy named Johannes
Blom Joan's lives with father sister
Nella and pet cat fly while playing with
his cat johans notices the hole in the
cabinet and blocks it with an old
newspaper trapping La Pala in the real
world Johannes and his sister don't have
a mother so they cook dinner before Mr
Blom returns home from work later that
night Johannes notices wapala and tells
his family about it but they refuse to
believe him enraged he talks about his
late mother saying that she would have
believed him this seemingly upsets Mr
Blom and before bed neller reprimands
Johannes for bringing up their late
mother and upsetting their father after
everyone goes to bed johans again goes
to the kitchen and to his astonishment
he finds his pet cat Frozen like a
statue puzzled he looks around and
notices waplala the latter tries to run
away but johans traps him inside a jar
after wapala calms down Johannes
releases him and they acquaint
themselves with each other when joans
learns that while Paula froze the cat
out of fear he assures him that the cat
is harmless and asks what Paula to
unfreeze the animal lapala agrees but he
ends up turning the cat into a stone
statue it turns out wapala is an amateur
and he is still learning about his
powers suddenly Mr Blanc comes into the
kitchen to drink water so johans hides
the statue and runs back to his room
with wapala the following day Nella
starts looking for the cat so Johan's
asks will Paula to turn it back to
normal afraid of making matters worse
will Paula first tries his magic on a
spider that's predicted he ends up
killing the Spider by turning it into
Ash suddenly Nella comes into the room
and sees the Frozen cat leaving her
stunned as she is trying to process the
situation while Paula comes out of
hiding and introduces himself Nella
almost drops the cat on the ground but
johans catches it and explains to her
that while Paula turned the cat into a
statue but he doesn't know how to undo
it later that evening Nella and the
other two go out to buy a Christmas tree
on their way back johann's neighbor
Arthur notices lapala and tries to grab
him unfortunately the little guy panics
and uses his magic to freeze Arthur this
upsets Nella and she orders wapala to
turn Arthur back to normal with Paula
reluctantly obliges but he ends up
turning him into a stone statue after
the failed attempt he gives it another
tribe at this time he ends up enlarging
Arthur's statue soon Mr Blom also
returns home and he is puzzled to see
Arthur's giant statue right outside his
home he calls him on the telephone but
the call goes into voicemail Mr Blanton
then shrugs it off and surprises his
children with dinner at a fine
restaurant however the children aren't
pleased and they ask him to take them
for a burger instead but Mr Blom turns
down the request saying they should be
open to new experiences in life in the
next scene the family takes their seats
at the restaurant and is expected they
are served healthy and expensive but
unappealing food therefore Rapala uses
his magic to turn the children's food
into hot dog and Sushi much to their
relief however this attracts the
attention of the uptight waiter and he
accuses them of bringing food from
outside into the restaurant Mr Blom
denies the allegation but the waiter
still kicks them out enraged Mr Blanc
gets into an argument and in this
process he accidentally knocks another
waiter down causing the ladder to spill
hot spaghetti on a patron the head
waiter loses it and he locks the Blom
family in the office and calls the
police Mr Blom starts panicking as an
arrest could make him lose his job
seeing the situation deteriorate the
kids finally come clean and tell their
father about wapala just as Mr Blom
processes this information the waiter
starts approaching with the police with
no other way out the family asked
guapala to do something and the latter
quickly turns them into tiny humans it
works in the police return back after
reprimanding the hotel for wasting their
time Johannes and others then sneak out
of the hotel and Mr blah masks will
Paula to turn them back to normal johans
warns him against it as wapala is still
an amateur magician however what Paula
reveals that someone from his world
might be able to help the net so the
group heads toward the blonde residents
they walk for hours but they are still
not able to scale half the distance to
their home Mr blonde eventually gets
tired so the group retires for the night
at a Chinese restaurant everyone falls
asleep but what Paula stays up as he is
upset about his incompetence it turns
out wapala ran away from his world
because he failed to demonstrate his
power Joanne's eventually notices him
and offers him some comfort the
following morning a News Channel reports
that Arthur's giant statue has created a
traffic jam and the authorities are
planning to remove it this worries Mr
Blom and he decides to immediately head
home vowing to save his friend he gets
carried away and almost gets caught but
johans and others save him just in time
Joanne's then comes up with an idea
turning a toy car in the store into
their conveyance it works and they head
straight towards the Blom residence on
their way they passed through a park
where they crash into a dog infuriated
the dog grabs the car with its mouth in
the ensuing struggle the car's door
opens and Mr blonde falls down breaking
his arm seeing him in excruciating pain
while Paula drives him to the hospital
there they approach a young patient
hoping she will be more understanding
the girl initially freaks out but when
johans explains their situation she
agrees to help she then speaks with her
doctor and convinces him to treat Mr
Bloom after a while the doctor performs
an x-ray of Mr Blom and plaster his
broken arm meanwhile the news reports
that the authorities have been unable to
remove the statue so they are planning
to demolish it it is also reported that
since Arthur's disappearance people's
interest in his books have increased
skyrocketing their sales Joanne suggests
immediately rushing back home but Mr
Blom insists on waiting till tomorrow as
he has already broken his arm however
Johannes is worried about Arthur so
after everyone goes to sleep he wakes
will Paul up and convinces him to
accompany him home he hatches a plan and
orders a pizza from a restaurant in his
neighborhood when the delivery boy
arrives the receptionist denies having
ordered a pizza this leads to an
argument and the commotion wakes the
girl up and she notices johans and will
Paula missing worried she quickly
informs Nella and Mr Blom and they rush
out of the hospital the girl then calls
out for the delivery guy and engages him
in a conversation as Mr Blom orders
Johannes to get off the delivery bike Mr
Baum says that he had promised Johan's
late mother that they will always stay
together no matter what hearing this
Joanne's eventually agrees and jumps out
of the bike while the delivery guy
leaves with wapala and the pizza the
girl then returns back to the hospital
after helping reunite the family later
as the Blom family tries to find a way
to return home while Paula arrives with
a conveyance a pigeon much to everyone's
Joy the group then heads to their
destination aboard the pigeon the kids
are excited to ride a bird and wapala
shows them his stunts however this
enraged Mr Blom so he reprimands wapala
for fooling around he orders him to
quickly take them to the wapala land so
they could return to normal
unfortunately this breaks with flawless
confidence and he lands the bird on top
of a historical building he gets
emotional and confesses that there's no
one left in his world to fix them it
turns out after failing his magic test
everyone mocked him so he turned them
into statues and anger when he cooled
down he tried to turn them back to
normal but with that success at last he
panicked and ran away but Paula says
that he doesn't want to use magic ever
again this infuriates Mr Blom and he
again starts berating him while Paula
loses his temper but this time he
directs it towards a statue of Atlas
bringing it back to life atlas puts down
the globe and breathes a sigh of relief
following this Johannes introduces
himself and commends him for carrying
the weight of the globe for so long
Atlas responds that nothing's difficult
if you act rather than just thinking the
words move wapala and as he gets lost in
his thoughts Mr bomb slips Johannes and
Nella managed to grab their father but
they also end up falling down with him
fortunately waplala quickly Springs into
action he turns them back to their
normal size and helps them land safely
wapala has finally gained confidence and
he thanks Atlas for his advice meanwhile
Johansen the others head straight home
as the city council arrives with a
bulldozer to tear down Arthur's statue
Joanne's jumps in front of the bulldozer
and tells everyone that the statue is
the real Arthur as expected No One
Believes him they simply start laughing
left with no options Johan's reveals
with Paula to the world this sends
everyone into a State of shock but Paula
then uses his magic to make Arthur's
giant statue small much to everyone's
astonishment after this joins asks Mrs
Arthur to kiss the statue as she obliges
while Paula performs his magic and
finally brings Arthur back to life the
couple is elated to see one another and
they kiss in front of a massive cheering
crowd Mr bomb also Embraces his children
and mentions that they are the best son
and daughter in the world later Rapala
turns nella's cat back to normal much to
her Joy he also brings the spider he
turned to Ash back to life the children
then decorate the Christmas tree and go
to bed later that night johans wakes up
to noises from the kitchen when he goes
to inspect he finds vapala trying to
open the portal to his world Jones is
sad that his new friend is leaving but
he still helps open the door to the
wapala world Nella and Mr blonde also
arrive and tearfully bid farewell to
waplala the movie ends as what Paula
gives his jacket to Johannes as a gift
before parting ways with the family for
good subscribe and hit that like button
to help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching